[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors julien sait bien qu'il va poser
les cas bien sûr avec plaisir c'est bien
qu'on peut se poser des questions on y
va tu poses des questions bien sûr à
chacun tu démarres de bernard montiel
après benabdallah si vous faites un
quatre à la suite pour vous gagnez vous
fait gagner milan cristian à un
téléspectateur inscrire à la mairie tact
et pmp jeu dans la question pour bernard
exactement quel concours de chant pour
logo une marque qui tient un micro miaou
the voice continue qu'elle chroniqueuse
de tpm paix peut-on retrouver comme
personnage dans fort boyard
delphine wespiser bien joué wikia choix
c'est bon le bolloc'h sur quelle chaîne
est diffusée l'émission les princes de
l'amour c'est trop tard botha on repart
avec maxime tennis on repart à zéro et
on repart à zéro
maman s'appelait le gagnant de la
dernière saison de top chef je sais pas
[Applaudissements]
peu de gym bernès est ce que vous
trouvez qu'ils ont de la culture julien
lepers dans quel sport peut-on jouer
pilier demi d'ouverture ou point car oui
oui
[Applaudissements]
et
les violer comment le désactiver ce qu
on peut pas le programmer pour un autre
truc est-ce qu'il peut pas de lien on va
on va pas pouvoir ça
est-ce qu'on peut pas faire un truc au
mot bougies il se met à danser mais sans
s'en rendre compte en fait bank est
parfait en fait il parlera il suivra la
conversation dans son jeu donnez moi la
main
fermez les yeux crois qu'il a de la
culture lui j
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui c'est très intense
alors attention j'ai maintenant que vous
allez entendre le moule
vous allez entendre le mot bougez vous
allez vous lever et danser comme si de
rien n'était et répondent aux questions
comme si de rien n'était et quand vous
allez entendre le mot fini venez vous
éveillez vous allez cesser de bouger
retourner à votre place attention aux
mots bougez vous vous levez et vous
dansez et quand vous entendez le mot
fini vous allez vous asseoir
attention tout va bien à l'accès ou des
tons elle dort où tout va très bien
c'est un temps sans nous merci julien
lepers on est reparti pour le quatre à
la suite pour l'instant il ya une bonne
raison qu'à mi lourds en gagne et on
repart avec gilles verdez gilles verdez
c'est à vous est ce que vous pouvez
répondre à ces questions sais pas
quelles émissions se cache sous
l'acronyme d'als d'aaa d'alsace date
dalstein d'une ric lescar oui ça c'est
bon mais pas de réponse
donc elle s'éveille dans quel pays est
née cristina cordula président wade
accord briques le caire couleurs et la
panthère du logo de la radio nrj noir
meilleurs joueurs noirs c'est non alors
mon chaton à toi quel jour un tonnage at
on sait cha cha
la troupe et ben voilà tiens tiens tiens
tiens cherche un chien chien chien c'est
pas prévu dans mes chiens c'est bon ah
non pas trop cher pour y retourner votre
passage à c'est fini mais qu'est-ce que
je fais là bas je sais pas alors toi
dans une basse c'est comme ça merci
francesca c'est beaucoup aimé dans la
séquence
pour l'instant on a trois la suite
adhéré suivez un peu c'est ça peut jouer
sur celle là c'est sure que jusqu'a
question attention pouvait gagner 1000
euros chez vous c'est répondez à cette
question à lille où une chicha oui et
elle jours à 10h50
chaque jour à 10h50 que remue des
candidats devant thierry beccaro et boul
ouais exactement c'est gagné
[Applaudissements]
alors ça vous donne pas envie de bouger
dans ses folles dans cette hausse
comment l'aider comment le détroit
comment le désactive à fond le 17 il
faut dire finie filippini fini merci